on the field for their moves and everything they thought this was the most comfortable
to be able to now it's um now it's seven which is here why defense is more spread out
they're taking up more real estate on the field through high balls and different attack approaches
which is fine so so from here my i'm relying on my mechanics here to be able to get that ball
where it needs to get to it okay so we're going to do three meters a three meter pass here
which is right here just so you guys know none of tony's fingers fucking work and his passes
his pass is absolutely perfect because of the technique you can you can practice on your thing
like this it's square to you if you want to take my head off i got i got eyes on you i know you
be games i coach the jews love the boys
heads on hips
i know you make it be games i coach the jews love the boys
heads on hips i know you make it be games i coach the jews love the boys
I got it, I got it.
Switch.
Back here.
Now take a step.
Look at, it's good there, it's good.
You might see my target hands, I see your hands here.
See that, Frank?
Target.
Nice.
Again, here we go, they're coming.
Square.
You can do that on your own, okay?
I'd much rather you do this than everybody's like,
you know, and yeah, you know,
there's a little bit of pussy on Saturday night,
so yeah.
Bit of a drop late news, so you know, yeah.
Okay?
Mark out three meters.
It's nail 10, nail 10 here, nail 10 here.
Okay?
I'm gonna flick my wrist there now,
because I'm guessing they're strong.
I'm gonna get their balls.
I don't need to, I don't need to spin it.
I just need to get the ball into his hands, all right?
Now I'm gonna look at you.
Let's see if it gets you.
Okay.
Get it?
Yeah.
Fuck.
I know best, you're supposed to say,
not best, but not best.
Oh, shit.
Okay.